first consider the expression for take
the quantity of negative 4 times X and
add 9 so let's see we're gonna take the
quantity of negative 4 times X well
negative 4 times X is just going to be
negative 4x and then they say so we're
going to take that quantity that's this
thing right over here and then they say
add 9 so let's add 9 to it so that's
this first sentence take the quantity of
negative 4 times X and add 9 that's this
expression right over here now select
the answer that matches the following
the sum of 4 and the product of negative
9 and that expression so let's think
about this the sum of 4 so we're going
to take 4 and we're gonna add it we're
gonna add it to the product we're gonna
add it to I'm running out of colors so
maybe I will do this in let's see I've
already used blue and you know I've ever
used orange I'll use green so we're
gonna take we're gonna take that for the
summer 4 and the product of negative 9
and that expression so it's gonna be
we're gonna add 4 to the products we're
gonna multiply negative 9 times this
expression right up here so it's
negative 9 times negative 4x negative 4x
plus 9 plus 9 now let's see if any of
these actually match what I just wrote
right over here so let's see this one is
for lo here we're taking a 4 we're
multiplying it times negative 4x minus 9
and then we're at subtracting 9 so this
seems very different so I'll scratch
scratch that one out
let's see seen this has positive nine
times negative 4x plus 9 plus 4 so this
is very close what's that's positive 9
it says negative 9 so I'll cross that
one out this one has 4 times 9x plus 4
well no we have negative 4x plus 9 this
is different and there are multiple ways
in the multiplying it by 4 instead of
negative 9 this one let's see we have a
negative 9 a negative 9 being multiplied
by negative 4x plus 9 by being
multiplied by negative 4x plus 9 and
then we are adding 4 we're adding 4 so
all to all you have to do go from this
expression this expression instead of
adding the 4 there and
adding the four there you just add the
four here and then these two are
identical expressions so we will go with
this one right over here